welcome to this video playing am step by
step super gariya right yep of the goon
felt ready for each for craziness again
ok so i think antis it was the capture
that that i usually played but h5 is in
fact interesting someone pointed that
out to me recently check yeah this is
actually have quite a good line for
white knight deform yeah i can also then
there is this position without a form i
can i can show you after the game and
it's even good for white or let's say a
bit more comfortable for white without
h4 plate and with it plate it's now I'm
really nice for white ok continue to
develop he's got a completely wrecked
structure now on the kingside bishop
here
hmm interesting yeah okay bye g6 is
saying interesting as a quite nonsense
but I'm so what I'm saying here he
needed to two together this okay but
what about if I play
hmm
hmm looks really shaky
captain dis dis look cheeky him
hmm and I don't seem don't see a good
line good really good one
if I go rook h4 ping Zhi Queen g2 king e
2 and 0 threatening and I can cancel
short threatening group g1 it's not
working yeah come on this one trans
luggage for trapping the Queen trapping
the Queen or not
yeah I'm not quite sure why you need to
play rook the eight instantly after why
just invested in a minute I'm going to
add some idea with king of one it's not
protecting the porn only okay but maybe
he has some some way to to muddy the
waters because rook and queen are here
the same on the same file so maybe you
can they cannot somehow use this pin but
I don't see how he should use it it
takes h4 light takes then Bishop f5 is
protected at 95 I have Quincy 323 now
and this wins this long diagonal the
lack resigns yeah another case of
playing too quickly let's just eight
seconds yeah but and Luke h4 is the
threat okay yeah in fact if the computer
just tells me King everyone this is the
winning move and like it's busted here
anyway hmm yeah I didn't yeah I didn't
see a great move but it didn't didn't
occur to me that I was actually winning
already like black has no movie a rock
edge for is so strong I wasn't aware of
that computer wants to go here but then
I've got Quincy three this is very
strong yeah
yeah white is just winning I didn't see
that of course my problem here was that
I I didn't I couldn't make the tactics
work like i was i was thinking about
this for example here check this is
quite interesting but then this move and
what am i doing then I didn't see a
follow up to that the computer actually
says this is a draw with rook edge for
some perpetual crazy but this I couldn't
make work so so this is why I went king
f1 and this is a good threat and it
seems that you cannot Perry that this is
quite lucky for me I wasn't aware that
this is so strong yeah interesting game
thanks for watching